[Musique]
dans des galeries interminable creuser
dans les profondeurs de la montagne
une équipe de scientifiques veut
comprendre le monstre glacée qui
sommeille au coeur des alpes
à l'affût de la moindre vibration de la
roche
ils vont traquer le réveil d'un géant
[Musique]
le glacier d'argentière
mais la montagne ne se laisse pas
facilement conquérir
et ces aventuriers vont devoir affronter
le géant en surface
le compte à rebours est lancé plus d'une
centaine d'instruments de mesure doit
être installé pour suivre l'évolution du
monstre
cet hiver
retrouvez géophysicien glaciologue
physiciens du signal
à l'assaut du glacier d'argentière
[Musique]